so you can either go with something
where you're a subject matter expert
because you're an Enthusiast and a fan
of that thing you don't have to be a PhD
in it you have to be a big fan of it or
you have to be skilled enough in it to
where you have some provable level of
Competency it's not something you wish
you were good at it's something that you
actually are good at
Roberto Blake welcome back to the
podcast our topic today is how to find
your Niche on YouTube and you have four
questions that reveal the answer you
recently came out with the book create
something awesome it's an incredible
book but break down these four questions
for us and the first one is what things
am I most passionate about break that
down
yeah no thanks so much Sean so I think
that this is something that is a
challenge for people because a lot of
people are polymaths a lot of creative
people have a lot of things they're
passionate about but the thing is you
only have so many hours in a day you
also everyone knows that they can't bore
their entire friends and family to death
every single time with everything
they're passionate about and that it
won't always work right so we have to
figure out what we're passionate about
because if you if you don't figure out
what you actually like and enjoy doing
that's where you're going to go and flip
from Niche to Niche topic to topic on
YouTube and it's going to be like
starting College over every semester and
then wondering gee I changed my major
every year why don't I have a four-year
degree why I see all my other friends
you put in four and five and six years
having success and making money it's
like oh wait could it be because I kept
changing my mind and I didn't commit to
anything so I think you have to have
something you commit to that you at
least like enough to stick with it
and how much time do you think I've
heard some people suggest that you know
you should predict that I'll be
passionate I'll be fascinated by this
you know for maybe a couple years even
like how long do you think it would take
being committed to YouTube if I'm gonna
start something how long should I stick
with it until I see results I think it's
less about like um a matter of years as
me as much as it would be a matter of
outputs uh it means for me there are
topics and things that I've covered on
YouTube but the thing is once I hit 200
250 videos in that genre Niche I felt it
was time to retire that thing the good
news is though I was putting out enough
videos to where I was adding something
else to an audience or at least enough
of that particular segment of the
audience to where they could cross over
and once I discontinue that topic
there's enough new people over on a new
topic and there's enough of those same
people because there was some
cross-pollination happening between
those topics so there are a lot of
people that sign up for topics I did
about uh camera gear for example which
I'm actually going to bring back to the
channel That those people that care
about camera gear a lot of them have
become content creators so I I didn't
churn all of them the people who cared
about video editing tutorials I use
Adobe Premiere Pro Etc well that crosses
over to content creation so there's not
really a high churn in terms of losing
those people and retaining them but
there's a point where I became less
interested in some of those videos
partly not because I came bored with the
topic but because I became maybe bored
with or not challenged Enough by the web
is making those videos and now I
actually want to start making those
videos again because now I have better
ways to make them I've started up again
and so it's a matter of reintroducing
that content so again just remember that
there are phases and seasons of your
life where you're passionate about
things but you can't really be too upset
that you lose or churn some of your
audience if you switch things up on them
the best thing to do in my opinion is to
add things that that same group of
people is very likely to enjoy and as
you add more of that if you have to
subtract something because you're not
interested anymore you're not
necessarily losing as many of those
people
so the first question is what things am
I most passionate about but these are
like filters then you layer on another
filter and that is where do I have above
average skills or knowledge write this
question down exactly so let's let's
even look at me the way that I handle my
YouTube channel because it's predicated
and built on my personal brand and you
you can argue that
um I'm an idea based Creator versus say
as much of a community-based Creator or
so on so forth or even a personality
based Creator what I have done is I've
looked at my career as a creative
professional and how I've made my money
and what skills I used and the thing is
the overall theme is can I use skills
and my interest and my passions to make
money so the thing is I've been
consistent in the message of my channel
no matter what the evolution of that is
well I can add skills on top of each
other and so I had skills in photography
graphic design uh and video and I
obviously use those because those are
skills you actually need to grow a
YouTube channel in the first place you
need to be able to produce an edit video
photography is going to help you with
thumbnails graphic design is going to
help you with thumbnails these things
are going to make for good quality
content creation basically in any Niche
no matter what so by using my skills as
Foundation I was able to say okay I have
above average skill in these and what
proves that I have above average skill
in my case was I got to do them and make
money at them before YouTube so I was
able to objectively look at myself and
say here are things I'm good at and I
was able to qualify that with here are
things people paid me for now if I was
going to do an entertainment thing I'd
be like what am I obsessed with and what
do I have more than above average
knowledge of what do I geek out over
what do I make my friends and families
ears bleed about because I won't shut up
and so for me that would have been
probably geek culture so I could have
done a Star Wars Channel because I could
talk about Star Wars passion wise I
could make a thousand Star Wars videos
and not be bored there's so much to
explore with that universe so I could
find a thousand things to not be bored
about with Star Wars and the thing is
I'm a deep Star Wars nerd so you can
either go with something where you're a
subject matter expert because you're an
Enthusiast and a fan of that thing you
don't have to be a PhD in it you have to
be a big fan of it and someone who's
like you know committed and part of the
cult by following of that thing or you
have to be skilled enough in it to where
you have some provable level of
Competency so that's where skill comes
in you have to be able it's not
something you wish you were good at it's
something that you actually are good at
and something that you can demonstrate
your ability to create value
hey we're about to get back into the
core content but today's episode is
brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com if you want to
start or grow a YouTube channel this
year and learn one of the most powerful
strategies for getting views and
subscribers right now check out our free
on-demand YouTube class available at
thinkmasterclass.com now let's get back
into the show
so you have some experience in it maybe
you've been paid for it or maybe you've
just clocked some time your friends ask
you for advice about it you've been
mothering for a few years you have a
couple kids they're all still alive you
can start sharing your lessons your
mistakes and what you've learned on
YouTube or you have deep knowledge if
you've read more studied more Googled
more and you're personally an Enthusiast
packaging that on YouTube can give you
another layer of benefit So you you're
passionate about the thing you've got
some skills or deeper knowledge about
the thing but the next question is is it
possible to earn money break this down
and how do we know if it's possible or
not
I think one of the things we have to
look at is you can look at in a couple
of ways one of the ways I love and you
know that Sean is I look at how many
like obvious monetization opportunities
exist in this thing and I usually use
um you know the seven streams of income
for Content creators to kind of fill in
those blanks to say
how easy on a scale of one to five is it
to make money with this way this way
this way one through seven and that so
that would be one opportunity the other
thing I can do is I can identify who in
that Niche is doing this full-time is
popular and okay how do they make money
go find an interview go find go look
them up go look up how much money they
make or their net worth or go find an
interview where they talk about money or
go look at you know well are they
sponsored do they have affiliate links
in their descriptions of their videos do
they sell their own product do they have
a membership site or a patreon or
Channel memberships like how are they
making their money okay don't reinvent
the wheel that business model is right
there and up for grabs so I think that's
very straightforward to determine
whether something makes money almost
everything makes money it's just a
matter of some people have proven how to
do it and how to do it better than
others you always like to say success
leaves Clues and I 100 agree with that
so you know what just follow the clues
and then the fourth question is is there
a demand or need for this break that
down
yes so you and I are big OG fans of
search and one of the ways we used to
look for things was okay High search
volume low competition let's go or even
if there is high competition it's like
okay the Market's saturated boohoo
saturated with what is it saturated with
an abundance of quality maybe it's not
does it have an abundance of people that
show up for our date The Daily version
of this like probably not so you could
look at it from that perspective and
then all right how big is this Niche how
many people playing in it how big is the
biggest player okay well what's their
claim to famous success all right well
how many what's the next how large is
the next second uh player in the niche
third fourth was the top ten look like
and when you realize that you start to
realize wait a minute there's a lot of
ways to play the game not all these
people are carbon copy clones of each
other and the market is not saturated if
I cannot find 1 000 people that have a
hundred thousand subscribers and they
all speak English and they all are in
that Niche it's probably not saturated
it's probably not saturated I don't
think there is a YouTube Niche really
like that where you're like in just one
niche of English speaking channels
there's a thousand people that have a
hundred thousand to a million
subscribers it's not usually the case
you and I know that there are only about
roughly uh less than 50 000 channels in
the United States of America that have
silver play buttons in YouTube and
that's spread out and diversified across
all the niches all the categories and
the unique personalities of YouTube and
half of those belong to Media entities
and corporations so I still don't think
there's anything that's so saturated
with new interesting and original ideas
at the highest level of quality or the
highest level of consistency or even the
highest level of value
powerful and so for more on this uh
people can pick up your book of course
we'll link it up in the show notes
create something awesome but use these
four questions to pick the most powerful
channel topic that's at the intersection
of your strengths your passions the
profitability as well as doing some
market research and for more resources
check out the book
nailing your Niche is one of the most
important aspects of success on YouTube
I love this conversation with Roberto
and actually if you're not subscribed
yet to the think media podcast
definitely subscribe wherever you listen
every week because Roberto is going to
be joining us for some future episodes
dropping more practical knowledge so
that you can grow your YouTube channel
and speaking of growing your channel if
you have not watched our free on-demand
YouTube class you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com or check out the
show notes it's updated with a strategy
that we break down step by step so you
can get views and subscribers and stand
out in a crowded Marketplace this year
so check that out and I look forward to
seeing you on the next episode of the
think media podcast
foreign